RIGHT. ALL RIGHT THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE THE COBIT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO ACCESS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. HOLIER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IT HERE IN
THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY A SENATOR STERN
HE'S HE'S- GOING TO BE JOHN IS
A LITTLE LATE- SO- I'M NOT
GONNA CALL UPON HIM AT THIS
POINT- TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS-
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. CRAWL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SEVEN SIX
EIGHT NINE FOUR ONE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WHEN MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE UNNEEDED AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY DEVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE. YOUR
DEVICE- THAT YOU'RE WATCHING
ON- OR YOU'RE LISTENING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FOR THE REMOTE
HEARING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHATEVER
EFFORT IS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS AS CLOSE IN
THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THE MAYBE SOME LIKE
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE%
JUST IN THE NEW USE THE ONLINE
TOOLS TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL OF PATIENTS SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
IT COMES. REGARDING LIKE THE
HEARINGS TECHNO. CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS I'M
INSTITUTING TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
MINUTE EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME
WHICH IS TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH. FOLLOWS WHICH
INTESA MUST LIMIT THE COMMENTS
THE NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. I WILL WANT TO
MAKE IT I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
UP FRONT THERE WILL COMMITTEE
SIDE. SUPPORT OPPOSITION FIFTY
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES EACH
PRIMARY MINT WITNESS WILL BE
PERMITTED AGAIN TO TEST FIVE
TWO MINUTES- THEN ADDITIONALLY
PERMITTED SIDE OF A MAXIMUM
TWENTY MINUTES. FOR WITNESSES
WHO MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO THEIR NAME. THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION THE
BILL'S LOUDEST IT WAS QUORUM.
MANAGING COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BURKE
YEAH. NUMBER CARE PORGES. WE'RE
JUST PRESIDENT CARRY IT ALL
PRESENT. WE HAD A PRESS. DAY SO.
THE BEST SO PROUD HERE. DID
ALSO PRESENT. ONCE HERE
GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG JONES
LAYERED STERN WAKE CAL SKI- I
CASKEY HERE WIENER. PRESIDENT
WIENER PRESENT YOU HAVE A
QUORUM ALL RIGHT OF COURSE HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED I WANT TO NOTE
THAT PHYLUM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
THREE THREE ONE BY CENTER LEYVA
IS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA EIGHT OF WHICH ON
CONSENT- GOOD FOR ALL OF US THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARE. PHYLUM NUMBER THREE SB
THREE TWENTY BY SENATOR EGGMAN
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB TWO EIGHTY BY
CENTER LAMONT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB TWO OH SIX BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE WITH AMENDMENTS FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR SKINNER FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB FOUR NINE EIGHT
BY SENATOR UMBERG FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB FIVE ZERO ONE BY
CENTER WHAT CAL SKI WITH
AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WILK AND FINALLY FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB THREE
SIXTY BY SENATOR WILK IS THERE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
CENTER. YEAR ALMOST THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BENSHI COUNTS OF THE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CENTER I'M BURKE HI
I'M BURKE AYE BURGESS. OR JUST
FIVE IT'LL I COULD BE AT ALL I
DID ALSO. THE ALSO AIKENS I
ONCE I HEARD. JONES LAYERED
STERN Y. CASCADE LAKE CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE HOLD
IT OPEN YES- WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL ON
LET'S MOVE DOWN TO OUR FIRST
BILL SB FOUR SIXTY ONE SENATOR
CORTESE HAS BEEN HERE FOR SOME
TIME GO HEAD CENTER CORTESE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY
ONE WHICH ONE HAS CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND FAIR COMPETITION
ENFORCEMENT BY ALIGNING THE
AUTHORITY OF LARGE COUNTY
COUNCIL OFFICES WITH THE PRE
EXISTING AUTHORITY OF THEIR
CITY ATTORNEY COUNTERPARTS.
CALIFORNIA'S UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND CITY
ATTORNEYS. OF CITIES WITH A
POPULATION OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. THE
AUTHORITY TO BRING CIVIL ACTION
AGAINST PREVIOUS BUSINESS
PRACTICES. HOWEVER OF COUNTY
COUNCILS DO NOT HAVE THAT SAME
WITH FORTY. A BY GIVING SEIZE
THE STATE'S THREE LARGEST
COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICES LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO SANTA CLARA
THE AUTHORITY TO BRING- THE SO
CALLED YOU SEE- ACTIONS SB FOR
SIXTY ONE. WILL CLOSE AN
EXISTING FORSMAN GAP AND ENABLE
THOSE COUNTY COUNCILS TO BETTER
PROTECT CONSUMERS IN THE PUBLIC
AND PROMOTE FAIR COMPETITION.
THE BILL ALSO ALIGNS WITH OTHER
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA. SUCH AS
A FALSE ADVERTISING LAW WHICH
BROADLY AUTHORIZES COUNTY
COUNCILS TO COMBAT DECEPTIVE
BUSINESS PRACTICES. SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE IS COSPONSORED. BY
SANTA CLARA AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES IN THE SUPPORTED BY
THE CONSUMER TURNING SIX SUMMER
FEDERATION. THE LOS ANGELES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND-
JUSTICE. HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS JAMES WILLIAMS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY COUNCIL- AND ALSO A ROD
CASTRO SILVA LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COUNCIL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
ALL RIGHT- YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
IF WITNESSES AND SUPPORTER ON
THE PHONE- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE- ELEVEN TESTIFY.
THEIR LIVES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN I'M
WORKING OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAMES
WILLIAMS I'M THE COUNTY COUNCIL
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY URGES THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE THE BILL HAS A NARROW
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL. THAT
WOULD ALIGN THE AUTHORITY OF
THE THREE LARGEST COUNTY
COUNCIL OFFICES LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO SANTA CLARA. WITH THE
KERN FORTY VARSITY TWENTY
COUNTERPARTS TO BRING ON PER
CAPITA LOCATIONS. ANY COUNCILS
ALREADY HAVE SIMILAR CORDY
UNDER ANOTHER KEY CONSUMER
PROTECTION STATUTE THE FALSE
ADVERTISING LAW. MISALIGNMENT
WE TO GET IN ADDITION ARE
OFFICES BRING. AND AFTER A
HEALTHY TOGETHER. ALSO HAMPERS
OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
DELINQUENTS. ACTIONS MORE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS.
YOU CAN HELP OFFICES A LARGER
IN THE STATE HAVE STRONG REPEAT
AND CRACKED RECORD. FOR EXAMPLE
THE SENATE CREDIT OFFICE IN THE
MORNING. FACTORS THIS IS THE-
EVEN APPLICATION QUALITY
CONDUCTED BY OUR EARLY. OUR
OFFICE RECEIVED HERE AT THE BAR
SO SHE MORE STAND BEFORE I
THOUGHT SECTOR LAW OFFICE. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. OUR ALSO
HAVE THE- INDEX A LITTLE OFTEN
AND COMPLEX LOOK BACK AT THE-
DOCTORS ALSO CONTRIBUTORS TO
WILL COOPER. WITH OUR LIKE
PICKING UP ABLE TO GET CHAU.
FINAL AT THE OPPOSITE PROVIDED
LEGAL TO DEPARTMENTS THAT
PROVIDE A RANGE OF SAFETY NET
SERVICES. OUR OFFICE CAN HAVE A
SENSE OF. THE FLIGHT HARPER.
ACTUALLY HAPPENS THAT'S BECAUSE
SIXTY ONE IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
PROPOSAL PALANGA FORTY MARK
POPULATION AND COUNCILS BUT THE
PERSON STRUCTURE OF THE UC
ALCON BAND MORE PROTECTION.
AND- COMPETITION ACROSS THE
STATE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AND I'M NOT GONNA
HURT OVER TO MY BOSS AND COUNTY.
ONLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER WILLIAMS
CASTRO SO YOU. YES I AM GOOD AT
CHANCE NUMBER AGAIN ON WHO
HONORABLE MAN OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RIGHT WE OKAY SO AND
I AM THE CAN COUNCIL FOR LAW
ANGELES COUNTY. NEARLY BOARD
SUPERVISORS IS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AT THE FOUR SIXTY ONE
AND WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. SB FOUR SIXTY ONE WILL
ELIMINATE BARRIERS THAT
SEVERELY LIMIT MY OFFICE IS
ABILITY TO PERSON ONE FAIR
COMPETITION CASES TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND LAW ABIDING
BUSINESSES. WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO PURSUE THESE
MATTERS ON A TRACK WHERE HE
COULD RECORD OF SUCCESSFULLY
MITIGATING COMPLEX FALSE
ADVERTISING CONSUMER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CASES. THIS BILL
WILL EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO
PURSUE THAT IMPORTANT WORK. L.%
A. COUNTY AS THE PRIMARY
PROVIDER OF SAFETY NET SERVICES
FOR OVER TEN MILLION PEOPLE.
ARE COUNTIES DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS
THE OPEN INVESTIGATE CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS INVOLVING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING THE
ELDERLY VETERANS IMMIGRANTS AND
THOSE EXPERIENCING POVERTY.
INDEED IN TWENTY TWENTY ACADEMY
SEED OVER EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
CONSUMER COMPLAINT. NOT HAVING
FULL AUTHORITY UNDER THE-
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW HAS
LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND LIMITED OUR
OPTIONS ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH MATTERS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
EXCITED FACILITY IN VERNON
OPERATED UNLAWFULLY FOR DECADES
RELEASING LED INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND IMPACTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. OUR LEGAL OPTIONS WERE
LIMITED BCAUSE EXIDE IS NOT IN
THE UNINCORPORATED INCORPORATED
AREA OF THE COUNTY AND WAS NOT
VIOLATING A COUNTY BOARD. IF SB
FOUR SIXTY ONE HAD BEEN THE LAW
YEARS AGO WE COULD HAVE TAKEN
ACTION AGAINST EXIDE FOR
VIOLATING STATE AND FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE CAN HELP US PROTECT
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND
PREVENT ANOTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE. LIKE EXCITED.
RECOGNIZING AN UNMET NEED MY
OFFICE ESTABLISHED IN
AFFIRMATIVE LITIGATION CONSUMER
PROTECTION DIVISION WHICH IS
STAFFED WITH FIFTEEN EXPERIENCE
RETURNING MANY FROM OTHER
PUBLIC PROSECUTOR OFFICES. AT
THE FORMER FARC FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR I UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF THAT EXPERIENCE IN
BEING ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
LITIGATE THESE TYPES OF CASES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
YES VOTE AND HAS GOTTEN START
PRUNING HERE THE HEAD OF OUR
AFFIRMATIVE LITIGATION AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION DIVISION HE
IS HERE WITH ME IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MR CASTRO SILVA-
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY LET'S TURN TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE'S
NO ONE PRESENT ROOM ONE TO
TWELVE- MISTER MODERATOR LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONES NOW TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE. ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX
ONE MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR SIX ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE. N. ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE. ALL RIGHT
AND JUST FOR THOSE- TO REMEMBER
ON THE PHONE YOU'RE LIMITED TO
YOUR NAME YOU'RE AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING SUPPORT.
MISTER MODERATOR. IN OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE TWENTY
SIX LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR MIKE
ABOUT THE- THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN OUR
NEXT COMMENT COME FROM THE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR NUMBERS ARE
CONCERNED ON BEHALF OF THE
CUSTOMER JOURNEY CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE QUESTION. MA'AM OF
FORTUNATELY WE CAN'T HEAR
ANYTHING. MISTER MODERATOR WE
SEEMED OF LOS THE CALLER. ON
RAIL LET ME LET ME TRY TO GET
HER BACK. IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
A WAY FOR ME TO GET HER BACK.
MOMENT PLEASE. WELL I'VE BEEN
HERE BUT OKAY LET'S SEE WHAT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OPPOSITION
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO
SUPPORT. MISTER MODERATE CAN
YOU TELL HOW MANY OTHERS ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT AND IMPRESSIVE
IN OPPOSITION AND IF THERE'S
ONE PERSON GOT CUT OFF COME
BACK. SURE WE HAVE WE HAVE TO
RIGHT NOW WAITING TO GET COMMON.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE. THEY DROPPED
THE WITH THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
TURN TO OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S AT LEAST A- ONE
PERSON OPPOSITION IF MR-
MATTHEW BUILT FROM ALL. OF THE
FEES ON THE PHONE IF WE GET
TURNED OPPOSITION. YES THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATT
BELTRAME WELL. I'M AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I WORK FOR
THE PAST TWELVE YEARS IN THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION UNIT. I
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WITH REGARD TO SB
FOUR SIX ONE WHICH GIVES FULL
AUTHORITY UNDER THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW THE COUNTY
COUNCIL AND COUNTY THAT HAVE A
CITY WITH A POPULATION OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
EIGHTY EIGHT RESPECTS THE ROLE
PLAYED BY COUNTY COUNCIL BUT
REGRETFULLY OPPOSES THIS BILL
FIRST THE BILL EXTENDS FULL YOU
FEEL AUTHORITY TO ATTORNEYS WHO
HAVE NOT TRADITIONALLY SERVED
AS PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. UCL
ACTION BROUGHT IN THE NAME OF
THE PEOPLE IS NOT A NORMAL
CIVIL LAWSUIT IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT CASE WHICH CAN
RESULT IN SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
TO A BUSINESS. INCLUDING AN
INJUNCTION AND SUBSTANTIAL
CIVIL PENALTIES PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS ARE NOT LAWYERS FOR
A PRIVATE PARTY THEY'RE TRYING
TO FALL SPECIAL ETHICAL
GUIDELINES TO ENSURE THAT
JUSTICE IS DONE FROM ALL SIDES.
NOT JUST THE PLAINTIFFS COUNTY
COUNCIL PERFORMING DIFFERENT
ROLE. STARKLY SERVED AS
ATTORNEYS FOR THEIR COUNTIES
THE ACTIONS ARE SUBJECT TO
ULTIMATE APPROVAL BY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THIS RESPECT
THEY'RE MORE LIKE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING A CLIENT IN
PROSECUTORS REPRESENTING A
SOVEREIGN. IN ADDITION COUNTY
COUNCIL SOMETIMES CONTRACTED
OUT LITIGATION WORK-
CONTINGENCY FEE LAWYERS WHICH
UNDERMINES THE PROSECUTOR IN
THE TRIAL OF THE THAT. IS THE
CORNERSTONE OF UCL ENFORCEMENT.
SECOND UCLA ITS CURRENT OF THE-
BY AN ISSUE PASSED BY THE WAY
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR. IT GAVE
YOU SEE ALL FORTY TWO COUNTY
COUNCIL THE ONLY A TO
ORDINANCES. IN ONLY WITH
AGREEMENT OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF COUNTY
COUNTY THE FORTY IN A WAYTHAT
IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
OF THE VOTERS. FINALLY THIS
BILL SEEKS TO FILL A GAP THAT
DOES NOT EXIST- COUNTY TO MIGHT
BE AFFECTED BY THE BILL.
ALREADY HOW DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
WITH ROBUST CONSUMER PROTECTION
UNIT. SOMETHING I CAN ATTEST TO
BASED ON PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
AND ALREADY HAVE CITIES IN
EXCESS OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. WHICH ALSO HAVE
INDEPENDENT UCL AUTHORITY
AUTHORIZED BY THE ELECTORATE.
ACTING OF THE BACKSTOP TO ALL
OF US IS THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHICH ITSELF
HAS AN ACTIVE CONSUMER LAW
SECTION. IN SHORT. THIS BILL
SOLVES A PROBLEM THAT DOES NOT
EXIST WHILE CREATING OTHERS
THAT WILL PERSIST. HE D. A.
URGES YOU TO VOTE NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR BELTRAME UP QUICK
QUESTION THIS BILL TRAVEL DO
YOU DO YOU KNOW THE POSITION OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S IN
SANTA CLARA LOS ANGELES INDOOR
SAN DIEGO COUNTIES WITH RESPECT
TO THE BILL. I HAVE NOT SPOKEN
TO. ANY OF THOSE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVES. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR IN OPPOSITION.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO AND WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ENUGU
CHERRIES ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA I APOLOGIZE WE NOT
BEEN BUMPED THE OPPOSITION SAID
BUT WE ARE ACTUALLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT ALL
RIGHT IN MISTER MODERATOR NO WE
MIGHT HAVE CUT OFF SOME IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR ANY IS IT ANY
ANY PERSONS ON THE LINE EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SIXTY ONE
POLICE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
NOW. AND I SHOW NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISS MODERATE LET'S BRING IT
BACK HERE THE CHAMBER- I SEE
SORT OF BORED JUSTIN CENTER
COUPLE EURO- CENTER BORDERS. IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON THE BILL.
PLEASE THANK YOU. WHEN WE WERE
THINGISBACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN COULD HAVE BEEN TWENTY
SIX CENTREBOARD DISS YOUR
MICROPHONE ON THAT. IT IS THAT
BETTER WELL THERE WE GO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WITH SOME
COOPERATIVE SIX WILTING YEAH-
WE DEAL WITH AN ISSUE- OR A
COUPLE OF ISSUES WE'RE BUYING-
THE CITY ATTORNEY- I BELIEVE
THIS WAS IN THE CITY OF
CONTACTS WAS WANTED TO EXPAND
THE AUTHORITIES OF THE CITY
ATTORNEY. AND THIS IS KIND OF
AN INVERTED ISSUE HERE. AND
HAVING SERVED IN BOTH THE CITY
CAPACITY AS WELL AS A COUNTY
CAPACITY. THERE CAN BE A LOT OF
FRICTION BETWEEN THESE TWO
ENTITIES. AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU HAVE REVENUE SHARING
AGREEMENTS IN MIKE MY CONCERN
THAT I RAISED IN THE TWO ITEMS.
THAT WE DEALT WITH THE
JUDICIARY- LAST YEAR THE YEAR
BEFORE KIND OF SPOKE TO. WHAT
ARE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS SO I STILL HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS NOW THAT WE COULD BE
PITTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER. LARGELY
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE SOURCE
AND SO. I THINK LOOKING AT THIS
RIGHT NOW THE AG. GETS HALF OF
THE PROCEEDS AND THE OTHER HALF
GOES INTO A WORD STATE DOES
HEATHER HALF GOES INTO THE
COUNTY. AND THE CITY TAKES ONE
HALF. IN THE DA TAKES A HUNDRED
FOR THE COUNTY THAT THEY
REPRESENT. UNDER THIS SITUATION
THE MOTIVATION COULD ENTIRELY
BE FORESEEABLE THAT COUNTIES IN
CITIES ARE GOING TO BE PITTED
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER IN ORDER TO
EXTRACT THE LARGEST SHARE. OF
THESE DOLLARS IN BEING CLIMATE
ENGAGE IN A GAME OF ONE
UPSMANSHIP GOING AFTER THE MOST
HIGHLY LUCRATIVE VIOLATORS. AND
I DIDN'T KNOW IF- IF THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL WHO MIGHT HOLD IN
THE HIGHEST REGARD- I THINK
HE'S A ACTUALLY FIND GENTLEMAN
AND IN HIS TAKING ON THIS ISSUE
I COMMEND IMPORT. BUT MAYBE I
CAN POSE A QUESTION ON THROUGH
THE CHAIR TO THE AUTHOR- YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ARE IN
RESPONSE TO. THAT INTERNAL
FRICTION THAT WE ARE NOW
PERPETUATING. BECAUSE I VOTED
AGAINST THE ONE IN SAN DIEGO
BEFORE FOR THAT EXACT VERY
REASON- THE SENATE CORTESE I'M
SORRY TO CUT YOU ALSO
REPORTERS. CORRECT SENATE
CORTESE D. WOULD YOU CAN
RESPOND TO YOU WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND TO CLOSE. A RESPOND
BRIEFLY YOU FALL RIGHT THE
PROCEDURE- THANK YOU SENATOR
ROOM FOR THE QUESTION IS A
FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND-
THE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND-
THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN THE
STATE- FEEL LARGEST COUNTY THE
BAY AREA I'M QUITE FAMILIAR
WITH- THE GENERAL ISSUE THE-
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS
OF POTENTIAL TENSION. THIS BILL
FIRST OF ALL UNLIKE. THE BILLS
THAT YOU- PARKING BY TO. I
THINK IT TO NINETEEN IS REALLY
NOT A DISTRICT BILL LEAVES
EVERYTHING INTACT IN TERMS OF
DISTRIBUTION. I THINK IT'S
TELLING- THAT- AMONG THE
SUPPORTERS- WE HAVE A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- IN THE WE ALSO.
HAVE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
ARE WE DO NOT HAVE OPPOSITION
FROM- LOS ANGELES OR SAN JOSE
WHICH IS THE COUNTY SEAT OF
COURSES IN ACCOUNTING SO THIS
BILL. IS ONLY DEALINGWITH
THREE COUNTY SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES AND IN SANTA CLARA
AGAIN WHICH I WOULD HOPE. HOPE
ALLEVIATE YOUR CONCERN TO SOME
DEGREE RELATIVE TO. OTHER
TENSIONS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
EXIST IN. A FIFTY FIVE OTHER
COUNTIES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THIS THIS BILL THIS IS
INTENDED. ONLY TO PROVIDE- THIS
OPPORTUNITY CLOSES GAP JUST IN
THOSE THREE COUNTIES. AND THEN
I'LL I'LL CONCLUDE THANK YOU
YES I'M I'M I AM AWARE THAT
ONLY PERTAINS TO THESE THREE
WHAT I ALSO. AM ACUTELY AWARE
OF IS- MISSION CREEP. THAT WHEN
YOU ARE CREATING OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE JURISDICTION TO EXPAND
ITSELF ESPECIALLY WHEN IT CAN
BE RELYING ON- THE REVENUE IN
THE PROCESS. IT'S ONLY A MATTER
OF TIME BEFORE MORE IN MORE
BODIES OF LAW IN MORE MORE
JURISDICTIONS BEGIN WANTING TO-
EXPAND THEIR CAPABILITIES SO
EVEN THOUGH IT'S ONLY
PERTAINING HERE. THERE MIGHT
BE- IT'S EXPECTED THAT THIS
WILL CONTINUE. INTO THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE IN THERE
AFTER. THAT ALL ALL THE CITIES
AND ALL THESE COUNTIES ARE
GOING TO WANT TO DO. THIS IN
THEIR OWN RESPECTIVE WAYS AND
THAT THAT'S MY ONLY CONCERN-
YEAH BUT I APPLIED TO- THAT THE
THIS IS ACTUALLY A DISTRICT
BILL IN SOME RESPECTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU- I SENT A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PER SHEET THAT I
AM. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY THAT CAME OUT IN
REGARDS TO THE EXIDE- EXAMPLE I
WAS LOOKING FOR EXAMPLE FOR
WHEN THIS WOULD BE. A GOOD
THING TO ALLOW AND THAT'S
PROBABLY THE BEST ONE THAT THAT
I CAN THINK OF CYPRESS SHEET
THAT AND I GUESS THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS WE LOOKED AT THIS
ISSUE- A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO IN
REGARDS TO THE BIGGER CITIES
AND WE ALLOW THE CITIES TO DO
THIS BECAUSE THERE IS A REAL
GOOD EXAMPLE OF- MALFEASANCE.
AND FRAUDULENT BEHAVIOR THAT
WAS HAPPENING THAT- THAT WAS
REQUIRED REQUIRED- THIS CITY OF
LA TO BE INVOLVED IN. IN BEING
ABLE TO PROSECUTE THESE KIND
KINDS OF CASES. I'M I AM I
GUESS I'M WONDERING. I SEE THIS
AS THE FIRST STEP. IN BIGGER
COUNTIES IN BIGGER CITIES
JOINING AND I AND I JUST WONDER
IF THERE'S ANY. REASON FOR THIS
TO SAY- A BIG CITY OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
OTHER THAN JUST MAKING IT A
DISTRICT BILL AS AS WITH
ARTICULATED- THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BIG CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
DISABILITY THERE'S THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF A BIG COUNTIES THAT
PROBABLY COULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED AND I'M IF I'M
WONDERING IF THE AUTHOR COULD
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHY THAT WHY THIS PARTICULAR
CUT OFF. ON AND HOW THAT- AND
THEN AND THEN I DIDN'T SEE AND
I DIDN'T REMEMBER IF IT IF
THERE'S A CASE IF THIS WAS TO
MOVE FORWARD IF THERE'S A CASES
PROSECUTED BY A COUNTY DOES THE
COUNTY RECEIVED A 100% OF THE
FUNDS OR IS IT ON THIS IS A
SPLIT WITH THE CITY THAT IS THE
JURISDICTION THAT IT'S LOCATED
IN. YES THANK YOU FOR USING
EARLIER THANK YOU. SENATOR
DAISY- THANK YOU- MISTER. LET
ME ANSWER THE QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO. FOR THE ORIGINS OF
THE BILL AND I'D LIKE TO. A
DEFERRED TO MISTER WILLIAMS
JAMES WILLIAMS ON THE ISSUE
DISTRIBUTION- BETWEEN CITIES
AND COUNTIES BUT AS HE IS A
COUNTY COUNCIL SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND- IS EVEN MORE
FAMILIAR THAN I AM WITH THE-
DISTRIBUTION. OF THIS BILL S.
AS MR WILLIAMS SAID IN HIS
OPENING- AT SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IS- A VERY LARGE AND ROBUST-
COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICE THAT WAS
LAST YEAR- NAME THE TOP- PUBLIC
SECTOR. LAW OFFICE IN THE
COUNTRY IN HIS HAS A LEAD ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES- RELATED AND
INCLUDING- ISSUES- IN IN OTHER
STATUTES THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED
TO BRING- IN TERMS OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION- THE LEAD PAINT CASE
FOR EXAMPLE THAT- WAS RECENTLY.
SETTLED WAS- HAD ITS ORIGINS IN
THE COUNTY SANTA CLARA THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY OF THE KIND OF
WORK. THE CITY OF SAN JOSE-
TYPICALLY DOES NOT TAKE THESE
YOU SEE ALL CASES WHICH ARE
ALSO GOES BACK TO THE PRIOR
QUESTION TO SOME DEGREE- THERE
HASN'T BEEN TENSION AROUND OR
COMPETITION. THERE ON AND THAT
WAS THE ORIGIN OF. OF REALLY OF
THIS BILL- AS A DISTRICT BILL
IN AGAIN COMING FROM SOMEBODY
WHO SERVED THERE AND WHO KNOWS
INTIMATELY- THE CAPACITY OF THE
COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE IN THE-
THE POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICE TO
PROVIDE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
UNDER THIS PROPOSED MEASURE- AT
AS WE DEVELOP THE BILL OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY- EXPRESSED
INTEREST AS DID SAN DIEGO IN
THE CUT OFF OF SEVEN EARNED
FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION WAS
WHAT WAS LOOK TO IN PART
BECAUSE I WAS A CUT OFF
PREVIOUSLY ESTABLISHED FOR
CITIES- SO TO BE CONSISTENT- IT
REALLY JUST ENDED UP- FALLING
IN PLACE THAT WAY SO TO SPEAK
BUT BUILT BY A DENTIST. TO
REASSURE THE BILL SPEAKS TO- IT
ENABLING JUST THOSE THREE
COUNTIES JUST THOSE THREE
COUNTIES- IN AND WE'RE NOT
SEEING ANYTHING OTHER THAN THAT
AT THIS TIME OF THE
DISTRIBUTION I WOULD DEFER TO.
MISTER WILLIAMS ABOUT- OKAY
WITH CHAIR. AND I'M CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER QUESTIONS
AS WELL- THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE MISTER WILLIAMS ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE DO YOU CARE TO
RESPOND. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE AND
THANK SENATOR COMING AT ALL-
WHAT I WOULD SAY ON THE
DISTRIBUTION IS THIS BILL MAKES
NO CHANGES WHATSOEVER TO THE
CURRENT. DISTRIBUTION PROVIDED
IN THE STATUTE. THAT MEANS THAT
IF THERE IS BACK IN ACTION
WHERE CITY ATTORNEY AND COUNTY
COUNCIL OR CITY ATTORNEY AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. IS INVOLVED
JOINTLY IN THE CASE SAID THAT
THE PENALTIES ARE SPLIT.
EQUALLY BETWEEN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY. AND UNDER EXISTING
LAW THE CASE THAT JUST
INVOLVES. ON THE COUNTY WITH
THAT DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
OR COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE. THE
PENALTIES. ARE PROVIDED TO THE
COUNTY TREASURER. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I PROJECT THAT AND I'M
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY I JUST NEED TO SAY THAT-
THAT THE FACT THAT THERE ARE.
ROBUST CONSUMER PROTECTION
OFFICES WITHIN THESE COUNTIES
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN MY MIND
BECAUSE IT MAKES SENSE TO
EXTEND TO THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
A GOOD THING- SO I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I'M SORRY THANK YOU
CYNICAL ZERO SAN WEARY OF
QUESTION. ARE THANKS IS MANY OF
ITS DIFFERENT. I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT
AS A MOVED ALREADY- I- AND I
SAID I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
SOME OF THESE- UNFORTUNATELY
WILL BECOME TURF BATTLES. AMONG
THE COUNTY COUNCIL'S IN THE
CITY ATTORNEYS IN THE DA'S. AND
I SERVICES A FORMER. DEPUTY
CITY ATTORNEY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FOR WHICH ALL THE
RESPECT L. A. AS THE BEST. OF
THE BLOG ENTRY. BUT YOU KNOW. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF
THESE- AND IS IF YOU'RE A LARGE
TECH COUNTY- CITY. D. A. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GOING TO COURT AND TO BRING
THESE. PUBLIC PROTECTION
LAWSUIT. I HAVE TO SAY THAT I
VERY MUCH DISAGREE WITH-
WINDOWS FROM THE- DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION THIS IS
NOT. A CRIMINAL SUIT THIS IS A
CIVIL LAWSUIT- AND I DON'T
THINK IT. IS ACCURATE TO SAY
THAT THIS IS THE SAME. AS WHEN
A PROCESS OF A DIEGO'S IN THE
COURT ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO PUT
SOMEONE IN JAIL- THIS IS A
CIVIL LAWSUIT AND DISCOUNTED.
WITH SUCH A THE LARGER COUNTY
COUNCIL TO TERMS OFFICE. HAVE
SIGNIFICANT EXPERTISE OFTEN.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPERTISE
THAN DA'S OFFICES HAVE. IN
TERMS OF. REALLY HANDLING
COMPLEX CIVIL LITIGATION CITING
THIS IS VERY APPROPRIATE AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU-
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS-
MISSED COURTESIES. CORTESE
TURTLES- YES MR IN- I ALL OF
THE- IN THE- CENTER CAR. OF THE
KERR TO. KEEP FOR EXAMPLE TO. A
POLITICALLY DINNER PMP SECTION
SEVENTEEN FIVE HUNDRED THE
FALSE ADVERTISING LAWS JUST AS
ONE EXAMPLE OF THEIR CURRENT.
CAPABILITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MICHAEL THANK YOU SO THE
CORTEZ'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WIENER- MANCHETE COUNSEL IF YOU
CALL THE ROLL. SB FOUR SIXTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG BY. AMBERG FIVE BURGESS.
FOR JUST NOT VOTING. COLORADO
HI COMMITTEE AT ALL I DID I
SELL I IT DOES SOI GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYERED HI LAYERED I STERN. BY
CAL SKI ARE Y. CASKEY I WIENER
AYE WIENER I. THE COUNTESS I'M
SORRY. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX EIGHT SEVEN TWO ZERO AND
LEAVING IT OPEN YES WILL BE THE
COUPLE THE ROLE OF THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S MOVE ON
NOW TO- SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
SENATOR ALSO SENATOR ALSO IF
YOU IF YOU CHOOSE YOU CAN
CHOOSE A PRESENT FROM WHEREVER
YOU. WOULD LIKE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- MISTER TURN
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
TWO NINE SEVEN- AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR OF FOR ALL THE EIGHT OF
GUIDANCE OF I HAVE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL BE INCORPORATED IF
THE BILL WERE TO LEAVE THE- OF
THE COMMITTEE- AND I BELIEVE
THE AMENDMENTS WERE INCLUDED IN
THE ANALYSIS. SALAMI CLARIFY
SOME OF THE REST OF YOUR ARE
YOU ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
HERE ARE YOU SAYING YOU WILL
ACCEPT THEM IN THE FUTURE THEY
THEY WILL BE INCORPORATED IF
THIS ALL RIGHT IF WE MOVE TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE LIMIT
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
NO AMBIGUITY HERE DO YOU ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS AS LISTED ON
PAGE SIX SEVEN COMMENT THREE
THE ANALYSIS- THERE ARE THE-
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE- THAT THE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES WILL BE
FOCUSED ON THE DEADLY.
EXCAVATION VIOLATIONS OF AS
SHIFTING FROM STRICT LIABILITY
TO KNOWINGLY AND WILLFULLY. I
REPEAT OFFENDERS ARE THE ONES
WHO GET THE I BELIEVE THAT'S
RIGHT BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN THE BELIEVES THE
COMMITTEE THAT THERE IS NOT
AMBIGUITY HERE YEAH SO- YES THE
EXCEPT THE MEMORIES ON PAGE SIX
SEVEN COMING THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS YES ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. I'M SORRY FOR INTERRUPTING
MAY PROCEED- OKAY SO THIS WOULD
A BILL WOULD CREATE THE CIVIL
PENALTY FOR UP TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
OPERATOR. OR EXCAVATOR WHO
AFTER FAILING TO FOLLOW THE DID
ALERT REQUIREMENTS. DAMAGES A
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION AND
CAUSES THE RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS
GAS OR LIQUID. CURRENTLY IF
YOU'RE GOING TO EXCAVATOR ON A
SUB SERVICE INSTALLATION YOU'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO CALL THE
EIGHT ONE ONE NOTIFICATION
CENTER. TO ENSURE YOU DON'T
DAMAGE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
BURIED BENEATH THE SURFACE.
THIS IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE-
THAT COULD PROVIDE ENERGY WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND SO ON.
IT IS NO SMALL THING WHEN AN
EXCAVATOR FAILS TO MAKE THIS
CALL. DAMAGING SOMETHING'S
BELOW THE SURFACE IS NOT ONLY
COSTLY AND POTENTIALLY
DISRUPTIVE. BUT CAN BE
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS TO THE
WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC. THAT IS
WHY THIS BILL IS. WHEN A SOLAR
COMPANY FAILED TO CALL EIGHT
ONE ONE AND DAMAGE TO GAS LINE.
SOCALGAS EMPLOYEE WAIT KILL
PATRICK AND HIS CREW WERE
CALLED OUT TO FIX THE PROBLEM
AND DURING THEIR WORK THE
LEAKING GAS WAS IGNITED AND
WEIGHED MISTER WADE WAS KILLED
IN THE EXPLOSION. THIS TRAGEDY
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED HAD THE
SOLAR COMPANY FOLLOWED THE LAW.
MORE SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES WILL
PUNISH THE BAD ACTORS AND
PROVIDE SOME INCENTIVE FOR
OTHERS TO SIMPLY CALL EIGHT ONE
ONE. I HAVE TO WITNESSES MISTER
ERIC HOFFMAN WHO IS PRESIDENT
OF UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA LOCAL ONE THIRTY TWO.
AND SHANE GUSMAN HIS THE THEIR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU SENATE CAREER
LET'S START WITH MR HOFFMAN'S
MISTER HOFFMAN ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN NUMBER GOING
WELL I'M SAYING THAT AS MONITOR
ALSO. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN- AND
THEN IT SEEMS TO ME MEMBERS
NAME IS ERIC OFTEN AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT HAVE YOU W. A LOCAL
ONE THIRTY TWO. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND WORKERS AT
SOCALGAS I ALSO SERVE AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY
URGING YOUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT
AND COMMITMENT. TO SB TWO
NINETY SEVEN THERE ALTHOUGH.
THE WAIT TILL PATRICK GOT
SAFETY ACT. ON JULY FIFTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE LOST
OUR FALLEN BROTHER WAIT TILL
PATRICK DUE TO AN UNNECESSARY
WORKPLACE INCIDENT. IN WHICH A
LICENSE CONTRACTOR WHO KNEW THE
RULES OF A ONE ONE THING ALERT
LAWS. PREFERRED TO BREAK THE
LAW. ONLY NAME OF GETTING THE
JOB DONE FASTER WHICH
ULTIMATELY LED TO OUR UNION
BROTHER WAY TO PATRICK
SACRIFICING HIS LIFE. IN AN
EFFORT TO HELP KEEPING HIS
COMMUNITY SAFE. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR. THIS BILL IS NOT IT IS
NOT INTENDED ADDING UNNECESSARY
RED TAPE OR BUREAUCRACY TO AN
EXISTING LONG BUT RATHER THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF WORKPLACE
SAFETY. BY PREVENTING BAD FAITH
CONTRACTORS FROM KNOWINGLY
COMMITTING GROSS NEGLIGENCE.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS BILL THE
STAKES ARE HIGH ENOUGH FOR THEM.
ARE HIGH ENOUGH FOR US AND I
BESEECH YOU ALL TO GIVE THIS
BILL THE CONSIDERATION THAT
WAIT TILL PATRICK AND HIS
FAMILY DESERVES VISIBILITY FOR
IMPROVED WORKER SAFETY FEWER
OCCURRENCES FOR PEOPLE TO GET
HURT AND REDUCTIONS IN
UNNECESSARY VENTED METHANE
EMISSIONS DUE TO VEGANS AND
BROKEN GAS LINES. AND WAIT TILL
PATRICK HIS FAMILY AND ALL OF
HIS UNION BROTHERS AND SISTERS
HERE AT THE UW WAY ARE WHO THIS
BILL IS FOR I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION FOR
THIS LEGISLATION I WANT TO
THANK OUR OTHER SENATOR MARLENA
DORADO FOR HER INCREDIBLE AND
INSPIRING LEADERSHIP AND HAPPY
BELATED BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HOFFMAN- I
SUPPOSE WE JOIN WITH YOU IN A
AND WISHING CENTER THEY'RE ALSO
HAPPY BELATED BIRTHDAY- THE
NEXT MR GUSMAN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHANE DAWSON ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL- AS REFERENCED BY THE
AUTHOR OF MR HOFFMAN THE
INTERESTS OF THIS BILL IS THE
TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED WITH ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS. AND THE GOAL IS
TO AVOID THESE KINDS OF
TRAGEDIES IN THE FUTURE AND WE
BELIEVE THIS. MEASURE PROVIDES
THE ADDED INCENTIVE TO SIMPLY
FOLLOW THE LAW. AND YOU KNOW
DIAL EIGHT ONE ONE SO THAT WE
CAN AVOID THIS IN THE FUTURE.
WE WANT TO THANK THE STAFF. AND
THEIR WORK THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS- THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENGAGE WITH FASHION AND HELPED
US. CRAFT AMENDMENTS THAT WE
THINK MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL-
A WELL REASONED APPROACH YOU
KNOW ARE WE DON'T WANT TO
COMPLETELY UNDO THE SYSTEM
THAT'S ERIC SAID- WE WANT TO
LEAVE THE SYSTEM IN PLACE THAT
CONTRACTORS ARE USED TO BUT-
IMPROVE IT SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THE LAW.
AND WITH THAT- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE CONTINUE OUR WORK
WITH YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GROSSMAN-
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEE NO ONE IN
ONE TWO. MISTER MODERATE OR ANY
ANY. PERSONS ON THE PHONE WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
RECOMMEND AGAIN ONE. ZERO AND
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SPORTS THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LIVES.
LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR YOUR MIKE
AT THE OPEN LINE TWENTY ONE
MIKE IS A. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ISRAEL
BALLOTS WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS AND BENDIGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF
BETWEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIS MODERATE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. AND MISTER
CARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I SEE NO ONE IN THE DELTA
AND OBSERVATION I SEE KNOWN IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I SAW
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE MAYBE
WE CAN LOOK AGAIN AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION- THIS
MATTER ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWO NINE SEVEN. FOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION SB TWO NINE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TOPSY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVENO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT LOW BRING BACK TO THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
SEE NO MICROPHONES UP- SIR
THERE ALSO- BEFORE WE CLOSE LET
LET ME EXPRESS OUR- CONDOLENCES
TO MR KILPATRICK AND HIS FAMILY
AND THIS SEEMS TO BE A
CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE MORE
REALIZATION OF HIS LIFE AND
SACRIFICE CENTER THEY'RE ALSO.
YOU CAN CLOSE OH I'M SORRY DID
I MISS A QUESTION- BILL'S BEEN
MOVED THANK YOU THE SENATE
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRED RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU CALL THE ROLL. YES THE
MOTION THIS IS S. B. TWO NINETY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI.
I'M BURKE AYE PORGES. GORGEOUS
I HAVE A AT ALL I HAVE A AT ALL
I DID ASAL. IT ALSO AYE
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
JONES LAYARD ARE LAYERED ICE
STERN. WHY CASCADE HIGH WEIGHT
CASKEY I WIENER BY WIENER I.
YOU HAVE EIGHT ZERO LEAVING IT
OPEN THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE
LONG CALL- BELIEVE WE HAVE
CENTER MEN NEXT IF CENTER MEN
IS PRESENT IF HE WOULD COME
FORWARD. ONE MOMENT THAT IF
SENATOR MAN IT IS WITHIN MY-
YOUR SHOT IF YOU COULD COME TO
THE SENATE CHAMBER. W'LL WAIT
A FEW MOMENTS.
ALL RIGHT I SEE
CENTER MEN HAS ARRIVED. SENATE
MINORITY ME A SECOND TO GET
YOUR PAPERS ORGANIZED- NOT AN
ISSUE TO KEEP US WAITING BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE AVERY
IMPORTANT WITNESS IT'S ALSO
WAITING TO TESTIFY- THE
PROFESSOR JAMES STOVER WHO'S
VERY BUSY AND IMPORTANT AND- WE
REGRET KEEPING HER WAITING VERY
IMPORTANT MEMBER OF MY DISTRICT
YEAH. SO SENTIMENT IF YOU'RE
PREPARED TO GO AHEAD I THANK
YOU CHAIR ON BERGEN THANK YOU
TO COMMITTEE STAFF AND TO MY
FELLOW MEMBERS. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AS WELL TO SENATOR
RUBIO I JOIN AUTHOR AND CENTER
CABALLERO. WHO'S COLLECTING IS
MEASURE. I'M PRESENTING SP
THREE SEVENTY FOUR. WHICH
AMENDS THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROTECTION ACT INCLUDE
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION. WHICH
CONSISTS OF CONTROL OVER THE
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY OF
ANOTHER THROUGH THREAT OF FORCE
OR INTIMIDATION. IN THE LAST
YEAR WITH CODED WE'VE SEEN THE
REPORTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA RISES TO ALARMING
LEVELS- MOST OF US WERE
SHELTERING IN PLACE STAYING AT
HOME BUT AS WE KNOW. HOME IS
NOT A SAFE PLACE FOR MANY
PEOPLE. THE ONGOING CERTAIN THE
MYSTIC VIOLENCE REPORTS OF
HIGHLIGHTED A CRITICAL NEED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR LOSS ACCURATELY
REFLECT. AN ADDRESS THE VARIOUS
FORMS OF ABUSE THAT THAT PEACE
CAN TAKE. LAST YEAR MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE JOINT AUTHORS
THIS BILL SENATOR RUBIO
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TO INCLUDE
COERCIVE CONTROL. DEFINED AS
DISTURBING THE PEACE OF ANOTHER
PARTY. THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
ON THAT IMPORTANT MEASURE BY
CLARIFYING THAT REPODUCTION
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IS A FORM
OF COURSE OF CONTROL. HI MY
WITNESSES CAN PROVIDE A MORE IN
DEPTH EXPLANATION ON A HIGH
LEVEL REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
SHOULD INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING.
EXCESSIVELY PRESSURING SOMEONE
TO GET PREGNANT- WITHDREW FOR
CERTAIN TERMINATION
DELIBERATELY INTO INTERFERING
WITH CONTRACEPTION USE OR
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION OR USING OTHER
COERCIVE TACTICS TO CONTROL OR
TIME TO CONTROL PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES. ALL THE TERM
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION MAY BE
UNFAMILIAR TO MANY PEOPLE THIS
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR IS
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO COMMON
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. A TWO THOUSAND TEN
STUDY LOOKING AT FIVE FAMILY
PLANNING CLINICS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ON THE
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AGES SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY NINE SEEKING CARE
THEIR- EXPERIENCE PREGNANCY
COERCION. THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN STUDY OF FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEXUALLY ACTIVE HIGH
SCHOOL FEMALES FOUND THAT
NEARLY ONE IN EIGHT HAD
EXPERIENCED REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION IN THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS. AND LASTLY THE NATIONAL
HOTLINE INVESTING VIOLENCE
FOUND THAT 25% OF WOMEN.
REPORTED THAT THEIR PARTNER OR
EX PARTNER HAD TRIED TO FORCE
OR PRESSURE THEM TO BECOME
PREGNANT. REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
IS ALL TOO COMMON AND DESPITE
IS WIDESPREAD IMPACT REMAINS
UNNAMED AND THEREFORE
UNADDRESSED IN CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS. TO ADDRESS THIS SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR PROVIDES NECESSARY
CLARITY TO CALIFORNIA'S
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BY ADDING REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
TO THE ACT. PUTTING A NAME TO
THIS HORRENDOUS ACT IS ONE PART
OF THE SOLUTION AS IT WILL
ENABLE AND HOW EMPOWER
SURVIVORS IDENTIFY THE ABUSE
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED. BUT THIS
BILL ALSO HELP JUDGES WERE
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION IN
ISSUING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. ALLOWING
THEM TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
CONDUCT IS LEGALLY DEFINED AS
ABUSE. THIS CRITICAL ADDITION
TO THE TVPA WILL HELP SURVIVORS
SEEKING JUSTICE AND PROTECTION.
SO I HAVE WITH ME HERE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY- PROFESSOR
DANCED OVER THE DIRECTOR OF UC
IRVINE'S DOMESTIC VIOLENCE LAW
CLINIC AS WELL AS DOCTOR TAB AT
THE PARK IN L. B. G. Y. AND
TEACHING AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEN- IS PROFESSOR STOVER ONLINE.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CARE AND
BRIDGING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JAMES GALLAGHER AND I'D
RECOMMEND PROVIDERS FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS IN A
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE CORRESPOND
FREDERATOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CLINIC. ON BEHALF OF OUR CARD
MANY CREATE FOR PROTECTED
COLLECTION. IN SUPPORT SB THREE
TWO. FIFTY IS SHOWING BECAUSE
WE PROTECT COLLAGE IS A
PERVASIVE IN HARMFUL AT THE
BEST CAN USE. OUR DID FOR
SURVIVOR TO TALK ABOUT AN
PROJECTIONS TO RECORD. BUDGET
IN MIND AND RIGHT. IN PART. ONE
YEAH CAL CANNOT DEPRIVE
PROVINCIAL PARKS. WHEN WE THINK
CUTTING EXPERIENCE AND BODY
COULDN'T OUT SHE COURAGEOUSLY
HER WE HEAR. WHEN SHE CAME OUR
LOCKER IT SHOULD BUT NOT CORN I
THANK YOU FROM HER EX.
INCLUDING SEX THAT MENTOR
PLEASE SB. PRESSURED HER TO
HAVE AN ABORTION BUT WHAT ARE
YOU ARE TO PURSUE. OKAY SHE
THOUGHT ARE CRITICS CASE CO
DIRECTOR VIOLENCE RESTRAINING.
MACINNES CAN I QUICKLY BY WE
PROTECT COERCION INCORRECT. NO
COMMENTS IN MEDICAL SCIENCE AND
COMPANY TECH. ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT GREAT OUR CLIENT HELPING
RESPONDED I CASH THEM BUT IT
HAPPENS SO OFTEN. EXEMPLIFIED
HOPE YOU SURVIVE PERCENT DENIED
PRODUCTIVE THANK YOU CAN HELP
AND WHY DID CALIFORNIA CODE
SECTION. SIXTY THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU. THANK PROFESSOR
STORE FOR THOSE DON'T KNOW I
MADE REFERENCE 2% PROFESSOR
JUST OVER A LITTLE EARLIER
PROFESSOR STOVER'S THE BETTER
HALF OF THE MINCED OVER A
UNION- NEXT WE HAVE. DR TAB
WITH A HARKEN. DR HARKIN IF
YOU'RE ONLINE. I AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M DOCTOR THOMAS OF
HER CAN A PROFESSOR OF
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE. ACTIVE CORROSION AND
SOMETHING THAT I'VE SEEN ON THE
WEEKLY IF NOT DAILY BASIS FOR
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS. WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE IN A CLINICAL
SETTING IS WOMEN ASKING FOR
BIRTH CONTROL METHODS THAT
THEIR PARTNERS CAN'T SEE OR
KNOW ABOUT. AFTER THE
DEPO-PROVERA SHOT A MEDICATION
THAT'S INJECTED ONCE EVERY
THREE MONTHS SO THAT OUR
PARTNERS CAN'T THROW AWAY THEIR
BIRTH CONTROL PILLS OR POKE
HOLES IN CONDOMS. THE TYPICALLY
ASK FOR THE HORMONE FREE
INTRAUTERINE DEVICE THAT GIVES
THEM HEAVIER MORE PAINFUL
PERIODS DESPITE HAVING MULTIPLE
OR OTHER LESS PAINFUL CHOICES.
BECAUSE THEY STILL NEED TO HAVE
A PERIOD OTHERWISE THEIR
PARTNER WILL SUSPECT THAT
THEY'RE USING A CONTRACEPTIVE
AND HURT THEM OR BEAT THEM.
THEY GET TESTED FREQUENTLY FOR
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
MONOGAMOUS NOT HAVING SEX WITH
ANYBODY ELSE. BECAUSE THEIR
PARTNER HAD MULTIPLE OTHER
PARTNERS BUT STILL REFUSES TO
WEAR A CONDOM WITH SAM. ON DAYS
WHEN WE PERFORM ABORTIONS THIS
LOOKS LIKE PATIENTS WHO UNDERGO
THE PROCEDURE WITHOUT PAIN
MEDICATION. BECAUSE IF YOU WANT
PAIN MEDICATION YOU NEED A
DRIVER TO DRIVE YOU HOME. AND
PARTNERS ARE OFTEN SO
CONTROLLING THAT SEES PATIENTS
HAVE NO FRIENDS OR FAMILY TO
CALL. WHAT'S MORE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO APPEAR SLEEPIER
ALTERED FOR MEDICATION WHEN
THEIR PARTNERS COME HOME FOR
FEAR OF AROUSING SUSPICION. DO
THEY GO WITHOUT PAIN MEDICATION.
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE ON LABOR
AND DELIVERY OUR PATIENTS WHO
WANT TO STAY PREGNANT AND THEIR
CURTAINS WANTS THEM TO
TERMINATE. I HAD A PATIENT
JUSTICE SUNDAY WHOSE PARTNER
HAD BEATEN HER PREGNANT AFTER
THEM TRYING TO INDUCE A
MISCARRIAGE. IT DIDN'T WORK IT
RARELY WORKS BUT THAT DOESN'T
STOP IT FROM HAPPENING. THIS IS
WHAT REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
LOOKS LIKE ON A DAILY BASIS TO
ME. AND I GUARANTEE THAT I ONLY
SEE THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG. IT
NEEDS TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT
IT IS AN INCREDIBLY POWERFUL
FORM OF CONTROL ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU DR HARKIN- I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY- TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT LET'S ROOM THIS MOVE
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE KNOWN
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MISTER
MODERATOR. OTHER ANY
INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE WAS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVEN FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ARE COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR
OUR FIRST COMMENT LET ME REMIND
THOSE ON THE PHONE THAT- FOR
PURPOSES OF NOW TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT- YOU NEED TO LIST YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S IT. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR. WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA SAN MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD BELIEVES
CALIFORNIANS FOR THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
TWO HERE MIKE AT THE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANNE ARCHER
AND I'M A CERTIFIED LAW INTERN
IN THE UC I'LL BLOG ABOUT THE
PILOT CLINIC AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. BLIND TWENTY
YOUR MICROSCOPE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS DENIED A
CLEAN MAN OF THE FAMILY LAW
SECTION OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BARS BAR ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR
IN ITS CURRENT AMENDED FORM.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF
OF NAY ROUTE RIGHT CALIFORNIA
IN TERMS OF PART OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A LINE OF
FORTY THREE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR
BRIAN ADAM CROSSWIND AND I'M A
MATERNAL FETAL MEDICINE FELLOW
POSITION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME RT
THANK YOU NOTES TO THE
OPPOSITION WELL. I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AS I LOOK THROUGH THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY. I ASSUME THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'RE
LOOKING TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NOW
NO WITNESSES THERE IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. FOUR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY SEVEN
BEFORE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BACK COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND MEDICARE I SHOW
NO COMMENT ON THAT STUFF ALL
RIGHT OF BRING IT BACK TO THE-CHAMBER I SEE SENATOR GONZALEZ
HAS A MICROPHONE UP SENATE
GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO SENATOR
MAN FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
IT ALWAYS STEM FOUNDS ME THAT
WE HAVE- THESE OTHER TYPES OF
ABUSES AND COERCION- THAT COULD
BE APPLIED TO. MALE AND FEMALE-
MEN AND WOMEN BUT WE
PARTICULARLY SEE THIS WITH
YOUNG YOUNG WOMEN AND I HEAR
THIS TOO OFTEN AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE SO- I WOULD LOVE TO
MOVE THE BILL AND F. WHEN
APPROPRIATE- SENATOR MAN I'D
LOVE TO CO AUTHOR AS WELL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD INTO YOUR- AMAZING
WIFE THAT I HEAR. HAS ALSO
CALLED IN THE PROFESSOR YES-
THANK YOU SENATE GONZALEZ. ARE
CENTER BOARD IS YOUR MICROPHONE
IS UP. THANK YOU I THINK A THIS
IS AN AREA OF LAW IT'S VERY
INTERESTING AND I DON'T WANT TO
GO I THINK I HAVE TO SOME
PROBLEM WITH THE MICROPHONE BUT
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH MY
YEARS I DON'T KNOW. NOW I
THINK- IS THAT BETTER THAT'S
BETTER. ALL RIGHT. I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK THIS IS A
VERY COMMENDABLE AND ALSO.
REFLECTS THE REALITY. THAT THAT
EXIST THERE IS THAT THERE
CERTAINLY IS BECAUSE OF COURSE
OF BEHAVIOR. AND AS IT PERTAINS
TO REPRODUCTION- I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BUT I
WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT- BUT
THERE'S- SOME COMMENTS- MADE BY
THE AUTHOR OR MAYBE ONE OF HIS-
SPONSORS OR HIS WITNESSES-
INTIMIDATION IS. BOB IS IT
LEGALLY DEFINED. PROFESSOR
THAT'S A QUESTION TO LAURIE
IT'S ABOUT THE QUESTION IF I
MAY POSE IT THROUGH YOUTUBE-
AUTHOR SURE- INSUBORDINATE OF
OTHER QUESTIONS THEY WE CAN
HAVE SENATOR MEN DRESS ALL
WOMEN'S CLOTHES AREN'T WILL- SO
THE QUESTION THEN I'LL PUT IT
IN A FEW IS THAT IS THERE A
LEGALLY DEFINED- DEFINITION FOR
INTIMIDATION. A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT COURTS
ARE INSTRUCTED TO INTERPRET
INTIMIDATION- BROADLY- AND IS
THERE ANY A RESTRAINT OR-
CLARIFICATION- THAT IS IN THIS
BILL OR THAT YOU COULD SEE
COULD BE INCORPORATING THIS
BILL THAT REFINES WHAT
INTIMIDATION IS YEAH BUT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY
A WORTHWHILE BUILT UP ALL
RIGHT- OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SINGLE POSADA
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM.
MISTER CHAIR- ABOUT THE TO GET
BACK FOR A THAT'S THAT CENTER
THAT ALSO THAT'S FAIR- I JUST
WANNA WANTED THANK THE
WITNESSES THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY
I'M I'M ALREADY A CO AUTHOR I
BELIEVE IN THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BUT
I THOUGHT THAT THE TESTIMONY
WAS TERRIFYING AND- I THINK
IT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT IF
PEOPLE KNEW WHAT WAS REALLY
GOING ON IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
AROUND THE INTIMIDATION AND THE
FEAR AND- THE- ATTEMPT TO
CONTROL THE REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
HAVE. IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE IT WAS WOMEN- BUT I
UNDERSTAND IT CAN BE EQUALLY
APPLIED TO MEN I THINK THAT
THE'D BE OUTRAGED AND SO I
WANT I REALLY THINK THAT
WITNESSES FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY AND FOR GIVING US. A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT THEY SEE IN
THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE AS OUR
MINISTERING TO THE HEALTH OF
AND WELFARE OF WOMEN. AND SO I
IDEA I WANT TO THANK- SENATOR
MEN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATE COVER YOUR EYES SO SEE
IT MYSELF OF THE REMARKS ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE- CENTERMAN
TO DO WANT TO ADDRESS US
SENATOR BOARDS IS QUESTION YOUR
CLOTHES I'M CONSTANTLY. AND IF
THERE'S A MOTION FIRST. IS IT.
CENTER CONSOLE MOVES AT I MAY
REFER TO MY WITNESSES AS WELL-
I I'D SAY THE ONE THING I
NOTICED THAT INTIMIDATION HERE
IS NOT IN THE CRIMINAL CODE SO
IT'S IN THE FAMILY CODE I WOULD
DEFER TO MY WITNESSES ON THE
CASE LAW AND STATUTORY
DEFINITION OF INTIMIDATION I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
SO WOULD THAT BE PROFESSOR
STOVER- I THINK IT WOULD BE
PROFESSORSHIP ALL RIGHT. MY
BETTER HALF YEAH. IT IS DEFINED
BY THE CHAIRS. ARE. I CAN'T DO
IT SIGNIFICANT THAT WE PLACED
EXPLAINS WHAT UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF DISTURBING THE
PEACE AND COLORS CONTROL I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SPECIFIC
DEFINITION AT BALLOT THAT WOULD
INTIMIDATION GOT COMPLETED
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
DISTURBING THE PEACE AND
COURAGE TO CONTROL. INDICATES
LAW- TO WHICH COST WITH OUT
TELLING AT DISTURBING PEACE
IT'S THE CONTACT SPORT. THERE
SIXTY THREE TWO. THREE IN JUST
A UP ON THE CENTER- I'M HAPPY
TO WITH YOU- IF YOU TO- WORK
THIS ISSUE OUT IT IF THAT'S OF
INTEREST AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS HERE BUT- I THINK THE
POINT HERE IS TO TRY TO CAPTURE
THE TYPES OF COERCION. THAT
OCCUR IN THIS CONTEXT OF
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION- THAT I
WANT TO THANK- MR CARE AND MY
FELLOW MEMBERS HERE- AS YOU FOR
TODAY THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM IN
THE FLICKS WHAT'S OF PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY. WOMEN AND- THIS
BILL BY NAMING AND DEFINING A
PHENOMENON THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN IT WILL
ALLOW FOR THE SURVIVORS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IT WILL
FACILITATE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
ACCESS TO THE CRUCIAL
PROTECTIONS THAT SAVE LIVES AND
I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL SAVE
LIVES. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE THANK YOU SENATOR MEN
OF HIS MOTION. BENNETT CHIEF
COUNSEL YOU CALL THE ROLL. THIS
THE SB THREE SEVEN FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER HI. AMBER
GUY BURGESS. BURGESS I COPY AT
ALL I HAVE YET I DID I SAW
ONLINE WITH US SO I GONZALEZ
HI. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYERED BY LAYERED ICE STERN
WHITE HARD WAY CASKEY AYE
WIENER HI WIENER AYE. YOU HAVE
EIGHT ZERO LEAVING IT OPEN YES
THINGS WILL EVEN CALL UP I
BELIEVE THIS IS NOW WE'RE
COMING TO OUR LAST BILL FOR
PRESENTATION THAT SENATOR
WIENER'S S. B. TWO TEN- AND SO-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
AREN'T PRESENT WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLE AFTER
PRESENTATION OF SENATOR
WIENER'S BILL. END UP I
UNDERSTAND THAT- SENATORS STERN
MAY JOIN US SOME POINT REMOTELY
BUT I DON'T SEE HIM PRESENTS SO
IF CENTER STERN'S OFFICE COULD
BE NOTIFIED THAT WE'RE NOW TO
SENATOR WIENER'S BILL WHICH IS
THE LAST BILL TO BE PRESENTED.
I WOULD BE GRATEFUL. ALL RIGHT.
SENATE WIENER YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR- FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS- BILLS ARE
SENATE BILL TWO TEN- PLACES
COMMONSENSE PRIVACY REGULATIONS
ON THE USAGE OF AUTOMATED
LICENSE PLATE READERS KNOWN AS
LPR SYSTEMS- BY PUBLIC AGENCIES
INCLUDING A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
LIMIT ON LPR DATA RETENTION- IF
IT IF IT IS NOT RELEVANT. TO
CRIMES OR VEHICLES OF INTEREST-
AN ALE PR IS A CAMERA MOUNTED
ON A TRAFFIC LIGHT ON A
VEHICLE. OR OTHER LOCATIONS
USED TO CAPTURE LICENSE PLATE
INFORMATION. SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ALE PR
SYSTEM THAT EXTRACTS THE
LICENSE PLATE NUMBER THE DATE
TIME LOCATION AND POTENTIALLY
OTHER- OFTEN SENSITIVE
INFORMATION. FOR STORAGE IN A
SEARCHABLE DATABASE. LPR
SYSTEMS ARE USED BY A MAJORITY
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AROUND THE STATE AND GROWING
WORK I THINK UP 270% NOW- AS
DEMONSTRATED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR AN AUDIT THAT I
REQUESTED BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. BY TWENTY TWENTY THAT
ALREADY CAME OUT AND IT SHOWED
THAT L. P. R. IN- DATA IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE WILD WEST ON
I DON'T EXAGGERATE WHEN I SAY
THAT- AGENCIES ARE ON FIRST OF
ALL NOT EVEN MORE FREQUENTLY
NOT COMPLAIN EVEN WITH EXISTING
LAWCENTER HILL AUTHORED A BILL
YEARS AGO TRUST. REQUIRES SOME
BASIC POLICIES THERE ARE MAJOR
JURISDICTIONS. OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT EXISTING
LAW. A AND THEN WILL WE ARE
SEEING- IS- AGENCIES WILL
MAINTAIN MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
DATA IN PERPETUITY DID I HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY KIND OF
INVESTIGATION OR SUSPECT A
CRIME- AND THEY'RE GIVING IT
OUT LIKE CANDY- TO BASICALLY
ANY AGENCY EVEN SOMETIMES GOT
NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES. COM
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY. OF THE
MILLIONS OF IMAGES CAPTURED AND
STORED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES LESS THAN ONE PERCENT.
BUT OFTEN LESS THAN A HALF A
PERCENT BUT THESE PHOTOS MATCH
ANY VEHICLE OF INTEREST OR
RELATE TO ANY. CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS IN LOS ANGELES
ALONE OF THE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION IMAGES
COLLECTED. ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND GENERATED AHEAD IN
TERMS OF A VEHICLE OF INTEREST-
AND SO REGARDING THE OTHER
THREE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILLION
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND- THEY
SIMPLY MAINTAINED- THAT DATA.
ONE LONG- THEREFORE COMPILED
THESE MASSIVE DATABASES SOME TO
OFTEN IN THE POSSESSION OF A
PRIVATE COMPANY THAT. DOES WITH
THE WHAT THEY WILL- THIS TYPE
OF INFORMATION AND SOME WILL
SAY THE OPPOSITION SAYS. IT'S
JUST A PUBLIC PLACE WHERE YOUR
CAR IS ON A PUBLIC PHOTOGRAPHS
BUT THIS IS BASICALLY MASS
SURVEILLANCE OF THIS
INFORMATION CAN BE USED TO
TRACK A PERSON DETERMINE THEIR
DAILY PATTERNS. EXTRAPOLATE.
THEIR SOCIAL CIRCLES AND SO
FORTH. TIME DATA KEEPING OF THE
TURNING MANY FACETS OF A
PERSON'S LIFE. BITES AND
SHIPPED OFF TO MANY DIFFERENT
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ENTITIES
EVEN ICE. WHICH IS WITHIN A
VIOLATION OF EXISTING LAW- THE
ALSO THE INFORMATION STORED IS
NOT ONLY- INCLUDE LICENSE PLATE
NUMBERS- BALL DATE TIME AND
LOCATION ARE OFTEN OF WHAT IS
STORED SOME JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES ALSO INCLUDE THE
PERSON'S NAME ADDRESSES DATE OF
BIRTH AND EVEN CRIMINAL CHARGES
IS ALL HELD IN THE POTENTIALLY
IN PERPETUITY AND HE'S MASSIVE
DATABASES FOR VEHICLES THAT ARE
NOT OF INTEREST OR CONNECTED TO
ANY CRIME. ON THE- THIS IS
SENSITIVE DATA IS SHARED. WITH
OTHER AGENCIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY EVEN PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
FRESNO IN MARIN BY SHARE THEIR
LPR DATA WITH HUNDREDS OF
ENTITIES- WITH SACRAMENTO
SENDING THE DATA TO MORE THAN A
THOUSAND DIFFERENT. ENTITIES.
EVEN IF THE DATA ISN'T SHARED
OUTSIDE THE AGENCY- OFFICERS
EMPLOYEES OFTEN VERY LARGE
ORGANS ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. HAVE ACCESS TO IT
EVEN IF THERE'S NO CRIME AT
ISSUE- THE CHP ALONE SAW ELEVEN
CASES OF DATABASE YOU MUST USE
INONE YEAR- IN THE CASE OF THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND AGENCY
PERSONNEL. HAVE ACCESS TO L.
PUREDATA AT ANY GIVEN TIME. BY
THE EXTENSIVE THIS OF THIS DATA
MEANS THAT IF IT'S ACCESS TO
RESEARCH IMPROPERLY THE THEATER
COULD BE THE BASIS FOR
BLACKMAIL HARASSMENT. OR THE
TARGETING OF THOSE WHO ACCESS
HEALTH CENTERS IMMIGRATION
CENTERS WHO ATTEND PROTESTS OR
OTHER SENSITIVE ACTIVITIES- SO-
I WILL NOTE THAT- YOU DESPITE
THE BROAD CLAIM BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE CAN BE A
LIMIT ON RETAINER. THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL DOES
HAVE RETENTION LIMIT WHICH IS
SIXTY DAYS- WE ARE PROPOSING A
MUCH SHORTER AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT WERE IN CONVERSATION WITH
CHP AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
THERE'S NOTHING ABSOLUTELY
MAGICAL ABOUT TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND WE'RE OPEN TO WORKING. ON A
DIFFERENT PERIOD OF TIME BUT
THE FACT THAT CHP HAS- A
RETENTION LIMIT- SHOWS THAT
THIS IDEA THAT THERE SHOULD BE
NO LIMIT. ARTIST REALLY HAS NO
BASIS ON. FURTHER A MAJORITY OF
THE CRIMES THAT ARE ENFORCERS
SISTER WITH LPR OR TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS ARE AUTO THEFTS
THESE ARE TYPICALLY NOT- YOU
KNOW MORE SEVERE CRIMES THE
COUNTY BUT THEY'RE TYPICALLY.
NOT ON THE SUPREME COURT HAS
REPEATEDLY HELD THAT WE HAVE AN
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY THE
GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES WILL NOT
AUTOMATICALLY BY SHOULD NOT
AUTOMATICALLY BE TRACKING US
EVERYWHERE WE GO AND WE DO HAVE
A PRIVACY INTEREST. ON MUST
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PRIVACY IN THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT. LPL SB TWO
TEN DOES NOT STOP LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM USING
LPR SYSTEMS OR DATA- BUT IT
REQUIRES THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
USING IT FOR AN ACTUAL CRIME
YOU CAN'T KEEP IT FOREVER. YOU
HAVE TO- ANNUALLY AUTO YOU'RE
USED TO MAKE SURE THINGS ARE
BEING DONE THE WAY THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE. BARCLAYS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL GO.
WITH WITH ME TODAY BY TELEPHONE
OR THE BOSS WHO'S THE DIRECTOR
OF INVESTIGATIONS. THE BILL
ALECTRA ODYCH FRONTIER. LARA'S
AND MY KATZ WITH A- WHO IS TO
READ DIRECTOR AT THIS FOR SHE
RIGHTS AND- WHO'S REPRESENTING
MEDIA ALLIANCE ARE OTHER
SPONSOR. RESPECT WE ARE FROM
IOWA. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER-
IS MR MAS ON THE PHONE. I AM
HERE. READY TO GO HE WERE READY
FOR YOU TO GO THANK YOU MR MAS
FLASHERS ACTIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WANTED
TO MOCK BY DIRECTOR BUT THAT
EACH OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION. RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE. TO PASS.
IMMEDIATELY BUT LEADERS OR ABLE
PR'S FOR CAMERON. ABSOLUTELY
PEOPLE BASICALLY DOCUMENT WHEN
AND WHERE THEY WERE SEEN
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY ARE
CONNECTED TO ACROSS. THE STATE
WITH THE GENERATE A LIST. OF
ANY ONE OF THEM. GOING BACK
MONTHS YEARS. OR THEY CAN PUT
IT IN ADDRESS LIKE YOUR HOME OR
PLACE OF WORSHIP. WHAT CARS
WERE SENIOR. THE STATE OF TO BE
USED SPY ON YOU OR ME BUT WE
SHOULD BE A SPECIAL ABOUT THE
VISION OF. IMPACT ON COMMUNITY
OF COLOR AND THE TARGETING OF
THE- WE RECENTLY ANALYZED DATA
FROM. THE AGENCY BUT CAL.
AGENCIES CAPTURE NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION QUITE
COMPLETE TWENTY NINE. THE COURT
TO THEIR OWN RECORDS WHAT POINT
ONE COURSE OF THE WAS DELAYED
TO THE TRUCK THAT MEANS THAT
NINE POINT PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE WITH OTHER. ANY
IMMEDIATE PUBLICLY OUR. PLEASE
CONTINUE TO WEAPONS WOULD BE.
THE DEBATE THE WHITE. WELL
CRACKERS AND BETTER IMMIGRATION
EIGHT ONE I TWENTY FIFTEEN
LEGISLATURE RECKON THE BLACK
AND SB FOUR THIS BILL WILL GO
ONE PORTION AT THE WHITE THEIR
ONLY PR POLICY CENTER THIS IS
THE RESPECT INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
THE BOARD. LAST YEAR AFTER
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION OF
PORTANTINO YOU SEE ORDER THAT
ALL FOUR FAILED REQUIRE.
AGENCIES WILL BE FAR LONGER
THAN DIGGING SCHERING YOUR FOR
WE GET BIG BASS THE CARD
MEASURES. FOR THE- HE TOLD. IT
WAS A 100% WITH THAT THIRTY
FOUR. ORDER BIGGER THAT A LAKE
ONE ZERO SECOND. HOW WE NEVER
PUBLISHED AOP OUR POLICY.
MEANWHILE AGENCIES LONG SCHOOL
WITH THAT HAPPENED HAD BEEN
CAUGHT. THAT'S THE COPY ONLINE.
YES I AM SORRY MISTER CATHOLIC
AVE CLOSURES. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE CATHOLIC I
THINK AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS TO PRIVACY AND MEDIA
ALLIANCE FIVE THIRTY DO YOU OF
LIKE PLATE READERS BY LONG
COURSE AGENCIES FOR MORE THAN
TEN YEARS. CALIFORNIA NEEDS SB
TWO TEN DIFFERENT END TO THE
MATH ELECTION OF DATA. INNOCENT
PEOPLE. ON THE OFF CHANCE THAT
MIGHT BE RELATED TO CRIME IN
THE FUTURE. INSTEAD OF
BEGINNING AN INVESTIGATION
AFTER A CRIME IS COMMITTED. NOW
EVERYONE IS BEING INVESTIGATED
BEFORE ANY CRIME IS COMMITTED.
LICENSE PLATE READERS ONLY
GATHER LOCATION DATA AND IMAGES
FROM VEHICLES LET ME OBSERVE
FROM PUBLIC ROADWAYS. HOWEVER
LIKE MOBILE PHONES IF YOU KNOW
WHERE A VEHICLE IS BANNED YOU
LIKELY KNOW WHERE THE OWNER OF
THAT VEHICLE HAS BEEN. FOR CELL
PHONES. ITS LOCATION. IT'S SO
CLOSELY TIED WITH INDIVIDUALS
LOCATION THAT THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT DECIDED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. BUT A WARRANT WAS
REQUIRED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ACCESS. CELLPHONE LOCATION
INFORMATION. THE INCREASING
PREVALENCE LICENSE READERS THE
ASSOCIATE BETWEEN OF. LOCATION
AND THE LOCATION OF THE OWNER
ARE BECOMING MORE TOGETHER AS
WELL. WITH CURRENT NETWORK OF
LIKE TO THINK READERS TO BECOME
TRIVIA TO TRACK INDIVIDUAL
MOVEMENTS. AND BETWEEN SIX.
KERN ONLY THE- HIGHWAY PATROL
SPECTACLE LIMITS. LIMITED TO
HOW LONG RETAIN DATA COLLECTED
BY LICENSE READERS. OTHER ON
PERSONALLY. IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
WRITTEN LICENSE. READER DATA
FOR. YEARS AND INDEFINITELY.
SOME AGENCIES SIMPLY USE THE
VENDOR DEFAULT WHICH IN ONE
CASE WAS SIX YEARS. HOW DO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DECIDE HOW
LONG TO RETAIN LICENSE PLATE
READER DATA. WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL ALL OF THEM HAVE DECIDED
BY OFFICIALLY PULLING THAT
RETENTION PERIOD OUT OF THIN
AIR. NONE OF THE TIME PERIOD
FOR WHICH LEGALLY METER IS
RETAINED WANT NEEDS IS BAY ON A
NOW OF IS USE. WAIT AGAINST
CIVIL CAN. IN FACT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR TWENTY
NINE CONCLUDED THAT QUOTE
AGENCIES MAY BE RETAINING THE
IMAGES LONGER THAN. AND THUS
INCREASING THE RISK INDIVIDUALS
PRIVACY. THE LAW OF DIMINISHING
RETURNS APPEARS TO BEAR THIS
OUT WITH CAN PERCENT OF QUERY
LIMITED TO LICENSE PLATE READER
DATA WAS RECENTLY. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU FOR TO
VOTE YES ON SB TWO TEN WHICH
WILL ALLOW LICENSE PLATE
READERS TO BE USEFUL THERE
FAITH THAT WHAT. THE OF
MILLIONS CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CATHOLIC AVE.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OF
IN SUPPORT THE PHONE SHOULD I.
THE AND THEIR ORGAN. AS WELL
THEIR POSITION. MISTER
MODERATOR ANYONE ON PHONE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT. AGAIN THIS IS OUR LAST
BILL SO IF YOU. ARE GOING TO
PRESENT YOURSELF NOW WOULD BE A
GOOD TIME. IT WE HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LIFE. THE LION
FORTY NINE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
YES GOOD MORNING- GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE CAN MEMBERS
THIS IS TRACY ROSENBERG CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CO SPONSOR MEDIA
ALLIANCE AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND PRIVACY TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A SPEECH.
THANK YOU. WINE FIFTY YOU'RE MY
COULD HELP- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JONATHAN CHANG- I'M A
RESIDENT IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M GOING TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. TEN THANK YOU. WHY
IN THE FORTY SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS
THE. YES THIS IS LUKE- ALSO
CALLED ON BEHALF OF OAK
PROBABLY AND SERVE OF A BILL TO
AND THANK. AND MISTER CHAIR I
SHOW FURTHER I THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT- IN THOSE IN UP I SEE NO
IN THE GO I SEE NO ONE IN RE
ONE TWO- AND I HAVE NO ONE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION IF THERE
IS SOMEONE- AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS ENOUGH OPPOSITION IF
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF RIGHT NOW
TO THE MODERATOR- AND THEN WILL.
LISTEN TO YOUR- MESSAGE
OPPOSITE. IF NOT MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD LINE UP
THOSE WHO CARE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO F. B. TWO TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. SEVEN ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT. AND WE HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH- LINE NUMBER. LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. JOHN LOCAL. L. THAT'S NOT
ABOUT THE PEOPLE BOB WOULDN'T
EXPECT THAT THAT THAT. YOUR
LONG EXPANDERS. YEARS. NO
EXPECT BY THE FROM EIGHT ABA
RECORDS AND PUBLICLY FOR VICE
PLATE IN THE OPPOSITE IS THE OF
A LIFE PLATE OF USED TO I. THE
VEHICLE AND IDENTA WE
REGISTERED OWNER THAT WOULD
CONTRAST WITH PHONES WOULD IS
IMPACTS THAT OF PRIVACY- FOR
THAT REASON YOU THE BILL WE-
THAT THE IF THERE ISN'T PUBLIC
SAFETY UTILITY OF THAT. YEAR IS
ABOUT. WHETHER PRIMARY
OPPOSITION I WOULD JUST NOTE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND WE
KNOW THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. IT IS SOLVE CRIMES
AND APPREHEND CRIMINAL SUSPECTS
AND CONTINUE TO DO SO TODAY
WHILE SOME CASES ARE SOLVED
QUICKLY USING THIS TECHNOLOGY
CAN ALSO BE EXCEPTIONALLY
HELPFUL IN SOLVING CRIMES THAT
OCCURRED BEFORE IN THE PAST. TO
SET THE DATA DESTRUCTION
TIMELINE THE SHORTEST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AND STASHING WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY HINDER THE USE OF
THIS VALUABLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOOL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION AS
MODERATOR. THE LINE TWENTY FIVE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATTERS ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME ALL
RIGHT- BRING BACK THE CHAMBERS
SEE MISTER WHITE CAL SKIS
MICROPHONES A MYSTERY CENTER
MICHALSKI- I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
HARPER OVER THE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT IS THE
OTHER PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO CREATE AN INTERNET.
WEBSITE AND TO DEVELOP SOME
BEST PRACTICES CAN YOU GIVE US
A LITTLE IDEA OF I KNOW YOU TO.
YOU TALKED ABOUT L. A. COUNTY
HAVING ACCESS I'M MORE WORRIED
ABOUT. UNAUTHORIZED ACCESS
SECURITY BREACHES THAT TYPE OF
STUFF WITH THIS. WITH THIS
INFORMATION HOW THE WATER WORKS
WITH THAT. SENATE WIN. THANK
YOU MR- I'M SORRY JUST BECAUSE
I SHOULD HAVE CLARIFIED THIS
BEGINNING ALL OF THE ELEMENTS
OF THIS BILL OUR RECORD OR
BASED ON RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
AUDIT WITHIN TAKE USE ALL BUT
IT WAS ALMOST ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE INCLUDED-
IN THIS BILL THE ONLY THING IS
A VERY AUDITOR RECOMMENDED.
THAT THERE BE A RETENTION
PERIOD BUT DIDN'T SPECIFY WE
MODE TWENTY FOUR HOURS BUT LIKE
I SAID YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
WERE FLEXIBLE AND- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE SOME WORK TO BE
DONE THERE- THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WEBSITE- THE MODEL
POLICY CETERA THAT IS ALSO ONE
OF THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THE PURPOSE OF THAT IS. YOU
KNOW IF IT IF YOU'RE A LARGE
LAW ENFORCEMENT. YOU MAY BE
ABLE TO LIKE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
CAN REALLY RESEARCH AND DEVELOP
A GOOD POLICY. IF YOU'RE A
SMALLER AGENCY YOU'RE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE IT.
LIKE OUT OF THE BOX EASY. FOR
JURISDICTIONS OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SAYS THAT
THIS IS A MODEL POLICY- AND SO
WE'RE JUST GONNA. ADOPTED AND
FRANKLY. THANK YOU VISIT OUR
INTEREST TO HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY. SO THAT THAT'S THE
PURPOSE- THE PURPOSE OF BAD TO
HAVE YOU KNOW TO THAT HIGH
QUALITY EXAMPLE OF WHAT A CITY
CAN DO. OKAY IT IS SORT OF
FULFILLING THE DESIRE OF THE
HILL BILL A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO. YEAH THERE WAS THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO DEVELOP THESE
REASONABLE LOOKS. MORE PRIVACY
CONSIDERATIONS WERE NOT SURE
EVERYBODY'S DONE IT YET SO- IF
I MAY SO A VISITOR. SURE YES-
TO BY SENATOR HILL BACK IN A
FEW TWENTY FOURTEEN OR
THEREABOUTS WHAT WOULD CAUSE A
BIT ISSUE FOR A WHILE AND IT'S
BEEN GROWING OVER TIME AND IT'S
GROWN INS DRAMATIC IN LAST FIVE
YEARS. LIKE EVERYONE WANTS IN
ON US AND SO CENTER HILL DID
THE WISE THING AND SAID OKAY
THIS IS STARTED TO ACCELERATE
LET'S TAKE A LIGHTER TOUCH TIME
TO TELL THEM THEY ALL HAVE TO
HAVE POLICIES IN PLACE. TO HAVE
TO DISCLOSE ETCETERA ETCETERA-
WATER AL ACCORDING THE AUDITOR
THAN A LOT OF THESE AGENCIES
THE NUMBER OF INCLUDING SOME
BIG ONES JUST IGNORE THAT
ENTIRELY. ON AND THAT THE
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR TO SIX
CELEBRATED SO. WE STARTED OUT
WITH A LIGHTER TOUCH DOWN WE
AUDITED AUDITED OUGHTA AND
FOUND SOME HORRIFYING THINGS.
AS OF NOW WE'RE HAVING TO TAKE
THE NEXT. THE NEXT UP. WE
WANTED TO DO THIS LAST YEAR OLD
SENATOR HELLO STILL HERE- BUT
HE- BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
DROP A LOT OF BILLS LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF CODE YEAH. THERE'S A
LOT MISTER CHAIR THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD THINGS IN THE BILL I
DON'T WANNA GET BOGGED DOWN ON
THE TWENTY FOUR HOURS BUT SOME
OF THE BRING EVERYBODY. UP TO
SPEED ON ON BEST PRACTICES I
THINK IS IMPORTANT STEP. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATE WHAT
CASKEY- CENTER THROSSELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL- I'M DISTURBED
BY THE LACK OF PROTOCOLS IN THE
OUTSOURCING OF THIS VERY
SENSITIVE MATERIAL TO PRIVATE
COMPANIES I THINK THAT'S THE
ESPECIALLY WHAT- BOTHERS ME I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TOOLS AND
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
OF. ALLOWING THEM TO GET. SOME
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED-
BUT- THE WAY THIS IS IMPACTING.
ON INNOCENT PEOPLE I THINK ARE
NEEDS TO BE. RE DONE IT IS ALSO
REALLY DISTURBING TO LEARN THAT
MANY OF OUR LONG LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
SHARING THIS DATA WITH ICE. R.
AS ALSO REVEALED BY THEM THE
STATE AUDIT- SO I AM- I LIKE
THE PROVISION AND- IN THIS BILL
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- TO PROVIDE THIS
POLICY- TEMPLATE- AND TO ISSUE
GUIDANCE SO. I HOPE THAT- THIS
IS ALL FIXED SO THAT ON. THE
PROPER INFORMATION CAN BE USED
IN THE PROPER WAY THANK.
RESIDENTS ALSO CENTER BOARD
STAGE IS YOUR MICROPHONE UP.
SORRY. THANK YOU. THERE'S A LOT
OF MEDIA COMPONENTS TO THIS
AND- I KNOW WE'VE DEALT WITH
PRIVACY AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES AND IT'S KIND OF
LIKE A HYDRO WHICH KEEP ON
FINDING MORE MORE- THINGS TO
DISCUSS AND LEARN ABOUT AND
MOVE FORWARD ON- I THINK. THE
COMMENTS ON THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR RULE HAVE MERIT. BUT I
WANTED TO JUST COME HERE FROM
THE AUTHOR- BECAUSE HE'S A VERY
THOUGHTFUL- LEGISLATOR ON THE
ON THESE ISSUES. THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT IF I MAY THROUGH THE
CHAIR- THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
THAT THERE WAS NON COMPLIANCE
SERIAL NON COMPLIANCE WITH SOME
OF THESE DIFFERENT
MUNICIPALITIES IN DIFFERENT
DIVISIONS AND SO ON SO FORTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT'S A
SITUATION WHERE- A COMPLIANCE
INCENTIVE OR MANDATE WOULD
YIELD THE RESULT THAT YOU WANT.
THAT ALLOWS FOR THIS
INFORMATION TO BE COLLECTED FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES-
BECAUSE THAT CERTAINLY HAS HAS
MERIT. IN THE TIME LINE WITHIN
WHICH THAT INFORMATION BE
STORED. AND DISCLOSED TO THIRD
PARTIES ASSUMING THAT THERE ARE
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE SUCH THAT IF A FINE WERE
IN PLACE. WOULD THAT NOT
RESOLVE. ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES
HERE. HI YES SO- EVENTS OF
QUESTION CORRECTLY- TWO THINGS
WE LEARNED TWO THINGS FROM THE
AUDIT WE LEARNED THAT- ASPECTS
OF THE INDUSTRY THIRTY FOUR I
THINK IT WAS OBSERVE THE CENTER
HELD BILL- WERE NOT BEING
COMPLIED WITH BUT WE ALSO
LEARNED THAT THE ISSUES GO
BEYOND WHAT THAT BILL. I'VE
DEALT WITH SAID THAT THE REALLY
DRAMATIC INCREASE USE OF LPR
BY MORE MORE AGENCIES AND
LEARNING MORE ABOUT HOW THE
DATA WAS BEING USER FRIENDLY
MISUSED- SHOWED US THAT WE NEED
TO BUILD UPON THE WORK OF IN
ADDITION TO GETTING COMPLIANCE
BUT ACTUALLY BUILDING ON IT.
AND IT'S QUITE LIMITED WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT THIS IS NOT A
KITCHEN SINK BILL REQUIRING.
THE W. RETURNS PERIOD LIKE I
SAID FLEXIBLE AND FOR FOUR HOUR
AND WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH.
ON THAT. AND THEN YOU KNOW
AUDITING TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
BEEN COMPLY BECAUSE THE AUDIT
PART WHICH IS RECOMMENDED BY
THE ORDER. GIVEN THAT WE SAW SO
MUCH NON COMPLIANCE BEFORE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
AN ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM AND
THEN REQUIRING. OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO HELP
CITIES COMPLY WITH TEMPLATES.
SO WE THINK IT'S A PRETTY-
MEASURED RESPONSE. TO WHAT'S
INCREASINGLY- REALLY
PROBLEMATIC SITUATION TRUMP
VERY TROUBLING. THAT AGENCIES
ARE DOING US. IN THAT'S IN
ANYTHING YOU CAN HEAR MY
CONCERN- ON THIS ISSUE IS.
INTUITIVELY I WOULD THINK THAT
THERE WOULD BE WAYS- WE'RE
PRIVACY COULD BE PROTECTED TO
SOME DEGREE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERESTS. HE LOOKED AFTER TO
SOME DEGREE- THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR RULE I THINK IF WE JUST
FROM MY FROM MY STANDPOINT. I
KNOW YOU'RE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT I HOPE YOU DO- IT. IN IN
IN REAL LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES NOT
ALWAYS DOES IT MOVE THAT
QUICKLY IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATION. AND I'D IN
REFINEMENT OF FOLKS. TO LOOK
AFTER OR PERSONS OF INTEREST.
THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE IN FACT. IF CHP'S
DOING IT FOR SIXTY DAYS- I
THINK SOMETHING LIKE THAT COULD
BE COULD BE HELPFUL OR SOME.
SOME TIME PERIOD LIKE THAT. AND
A FINANCIAL PENALTY OR SOME
SORT OF REGULATORY PENALTY FOR.
THE DISCLOSURE OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR UNINTENDED
PURPOSES. THAT DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT TO ME. IF IT IS INDEED
GOING TO THIRD PARTIES- THAT DO
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORIZATION TO
USE THAT- I KNOW I KNOW THIS
SEEMS TO BE A WORK IN PROGRESS
IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE
MODIFIED IS. IS TIMELY TIMES GO
ON BUT IF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER- I'M
I'M HOPEFUL THAT YOU THAT YOU
WOULD. TAKE TAKE A GANDER AT
SOME OF THESE SOME OF THESE.
POINTS ON BECAUSE THERE'S A
BALANCE. RIGHT NOW I THINK IT'S
IN BAD BY MAYBE A SOME POINT AT
LEAST IN MY- IT COULD BE A
BALANCE BETWEEN PRIVACY AND-
THE EFFICACY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL. THANK YOU SIR
BORDERS OTHER QUESTIONS. SAYING
NONE OF THE SENATE CABALLERO.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANNA- THERE IT DID THIS
IS BEEN BROUGHT UP IN TERMS OF
WORKING WITH THE POLICE
AGENCIES I THINK THE HIGHWAY
PATROL SAID SIXTY DAYS BUT I
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I. I INTEND TO SUPPORT THE
BILL- THE FACT THAT THI
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN IN EFFECT
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
NOTHING'S BEEN DONE TO-
PROTECT- THAT THEDATA IS BEING
COLLECTED IS REALLY OF CONCERN
AND SO- I WANT ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO WORK WITH THE POLICE
AGENCY THAT I DON'T THINK A-
THAT TIME HEARD IN LISTED IN
THE BILL IS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME BUT I TRUST THAT THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL WILL WORK WITH
THEM. THANK YOU CYNICAL HERE.
ANYONE ELSE I ASSUME GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- YOU TO
SENATOR WIENER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I JUST HAD A
THOUGHT AND- I KNOW THAT THE
AUDITOR HAD INCLUDED-
ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE I THINK-
SHE HAD RECOMMENDED C. JUST
COMPLIANCE WHICH MOST- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WOULD HAVE
TO DO WITH. CERTAIN TYPES OF
DATA BUT SINCE W'RE-
REINVENTING WHAT L. A. L. P. R.
DATA WHERE THEY CAN WORK CAN
GO. MY CONCERN IS THAT THERE
ARE FEW AGENCIES NOW THAT ARE
CURRENTLY- COMPLYING WITH
SIEGES. BUT THAT WOULD ASSUME
COMPLIANCE WITH IN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE FBI. SO
THAT IS CONCERNING TO ME- AND
SO I'M JUST WONDERING. THIS IS
FOR A LATER DISCUSSION THOUGH
AS YOUR YOU KNOW INVOLVING THE
BILL IS. IF THIS DATA WOULD
STILL HAVE TO. UP IF IT WOULD
STILL COMPLY OR WOULD IT STILL
BE NECESSARY FOR IT TO COMPLY
WITH SIEGES THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INFORMATION SYSTEM.
DATA ARM WE WILL LET ME SEE IF
I COULD CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU ON
THAT I JUST CAN'T RECALL
AFFECTS MANDATED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW OR NOT- WE ACTUALLY DON'T
WANT THEM TO BE SHARING WITH
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AT ALL- AND WE THINK
THAT ACTUALLY UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW WE DON'T THINK
THEY'RE ALLOWED. TO DO THAT
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE MOST
FOCUS ON ICE- BUT WE'LL GO BACK
AND TAKE A LOOK AT AT THE FBI-
AS WELL YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
WOULD LIKE YEAH WOULD BE GREAT
TO CLARIFY THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WILL GIVE NOT HAVE YOUR
OWN HOUSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATORS ALSO OTHERS- AND I
NOTED SENATOR STERN IS PRESENT
REMOTELY A SENATOR STERN WE'RE
GOING TO COME TO YOU IF YOU
WOULD LET US KNOW WHO- THE
STAFF PERSON THIS IS IN YOUR
OFFICE. AND JUST DIRECTOR.
WELLS BE WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN- I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT- AS A
REMINDER IT WOULD BE. USEFUL
IF. WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAK IF
YOU JUST PUT A SOME YOU DON'T
THINK YOU HAVE BUT JUST AS A
REMINDER. SO THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN CLOSURES. I'M I DON'T
WANT TO. BE LABOR ANY POINTS OR
PARTY MADE AT THEIR EXCELLENT
BILLS MUCH NEEDED. SOME AGREE
JUST. A OVERREACH HERE CURIOUS
WHAT SORT OF RECOURSE THERE
WILL BE UNDER EXISTING LAW ALSO
FOR- UNDERSEA CPA OR UNDER THE
HILLDALE RENDER PROP TWENTY
FOUR FOUR- VIGILANT. TYPE
SYSTEMS EVEN IF THEY VIOLATE
THEIR CONTRACTS POTENTIALLY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL KIND
OF. SEVERAL ABILITY THERE MIGHT
BE AS WELL BUT I JUST WANTED.
TO SEE. IF THE AUTHORS- AT ALL.
INTERESTED IN SHARING. SOME OF
HIS THINKING ABOUT. HOW HOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT THAT
TWENTY FOUR HOUR PROVISION IS
IT IS IT REALLY ABOUT PERK
INCIDENT BECAUSE THIS IT SEEMS
LIKE THE GENERAL HOTLIST IS
THIS AREA THAT. THAT FOLKS WANT
TO BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW HOW
HAVE SOME KIND OF CROSS
REFERENCE ON IT IS IT IS IT
MORE THE POLICY ISSUE AROUND.
HAVING THAT HOT LIST BE TO
CROSS REFERENCE FOR TOO LONG OR
IS IT MORE THE POLICY ISSUE OF-
AND CIRCLE OF THE TIMING OF
INDIVIDUAL INVESTIGATION. RON
AND YOU CAN COUNT ON YOUR
CLOTHES TOO I JUST I WANT TO I
WAS JUST HOPING TO DIG DEEPER
INTO THAT TENSION BETWEEN. THE
BILLS- TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD
AND THEN THE SORT OF STANDARD
PROTOCOLS LIKE. WHAT ARE THE
WHAT IFS POLICY ARGUMENTS FOR.
AND BIG DIFFERENCE HERE IT'S
TIME. NO I CAN ANSWER THAT NOW-
SO I MEAN I THINK OUR JOB THE
REASON WHAT WITH THE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AND AS I MENTIONED
WE'RE REFLECTS UPON IT AND
THEN- OVER GOING TO KEEP
WORKING ON THAT IS THAT WE
THINK THAT THAT IS A TOUGH TIME
IT'S A VERY FAST PROCESS THAT
THEY- GET THOSE DATA. IT'S
UPLOADED. AND THEN EITHER
MATCHES WITH A CAR THAT'S ON
THE HOLLISTER NOT. REGARD CARDS
BEEN STOLEN- SPOTTED IN
CONNECTION WITH A CRIME. AND IF
IT'S NOT THEN I THINK HE WAS.
WHY ARE YOU KEEPING THAT DATA-
SOUL AND THE SAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS SAYING WE WANT
TO KEEP IT FOR. I MEAN. A LOT
OF LAW ENFORCERS SAYING WE WANT
TO KEEP IT FOREVER AND DON'T
TELL US WHAT TO DO AND WE WANT
TO GIVE IT OUT TO EVERYONE IN
THE SUN. WE CAN DO THAT
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT GONNA GROUP
THAT. BUT AT LEAST AND I WANT
TO KEEP YOU KNOW. EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE WE'RE NOT FULLY ALIGNED
WITH THE SIXTY DAYS. ON A
COMMAND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL WITHOUT BEING TOLD TO DO
SO. FOR DOING THE RESPONSIBLE
THING- AND IMPLEMENTING- A
LIMITATION THAT THAT'S
COMMENDABLE I REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND. YOU FOR DOING THAT-%
AND WE WILL. BE ENGAGING HAVING
A MORE IN DEPTH DISCUSSIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT. WHAT IS THE RIGHT
PERIOD OF TIME. IN TERMS OF
THAT SORT OF MORE WE'RE
LOOKING- SITUATION. AGAIN WE
THOUGHT TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
PROPOSED EITHER ON THE HOT LIST
ABOUT POINT OR NOT. IF THERE
ARE YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
OPEN TO. YOU KNOW A FACT BASED
DISCUSSION OF WHY THEY WOULD
NEED X. AMOUNT. OF TIME ON SO
THAT THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF A
GENERAL. FUND. ABOUT THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR WIENER
QUESTION COMMENTS. SEEING NO-
IS OUR MOTION. CENTER GONZALEZ
BOTH THE BILL SENATE WAIT CARE
CLOSE JEFF- BRIEFLY RETURNED
AYE AYE I WANNA. YOU KNOW THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT KEEPS RAISING
THAT THERE'S NO EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY WHEN YOUR LICENSE PLATE
IS VIEWED ON A IS A SITTING
THERE ON THE STREET- AN AND YES
YOU ARE OUT IN THE PUBLIC THAT
IS VERY VERY DIFFERENT. THAN
HAVING THE GOVERNMENT CONDUCT A
MASS SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM BY
ACCUMULATING DATA THAT SHOWS
WHERE YOU ARE AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT IN TIME THAT RAISES
SERIOUS PRIVACY CONCERNS AGO
WAY BEYOND SAYS YOU HAVE YOUR
CAR ON THE STREET AND SOMEONE
VIEWS. YOUR LICENSE PLATE AND
THIS IS THE GOVERNMENT DOING IT
IT'S NOT THE IPHONE THAT YOU
CHOOSE TO. PURCHASE AND THAT
YOU CHOOSE TO HAVE LOCATION
SERVICES ALL WE CAN MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT THAT IS THE
GOVERNMENT DOING THAT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE IN TERMS OF HOW
IT'S BEING DONE- AND SP TWO
TIMED WILL PUT SOME LONG
OVERDUE VERY REASONABLE
CONSTRAINTS AROUND THIS PROCESS
FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER IN CENTER WIENER AYE. I
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN- HAVING A-
WITH RESPECT THE TIME. I TAKE
YOU AT YOUR WORD WITH RESPECT
ALSO WITH RESPECT TO WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THOSE
OF US THAT THAT SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. FOR
MESSAGES BEEN AMPLY DELIVERED
AND I HEARD AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE A SOVEREIGN ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU- BENCI COUNSEL
IF YOU CALL THE ROLL. I YES THE
MOTION IS OKAY THIS IS S. B. T.
TEN MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER HI. I'M
BURKE AYE BURGESS NO FOR JUST
NOW CABALLERO HI. I DID ALSO.
ADDRESS SO I GONZALEZ I AND I
HURT HI HERTZBERG I JOHN.
LOADING JONES NOT VOTER.
LAYERED HI LAYERED ICE STERN.
YOUR NINE STERN I LIKE HOUSE
GERHARD WIECKOWSKI AYE WIENER
HI WIENER HI THAT'S NINE TWO
ONE. NINETY ONE THE BILL IS
OUT- JUST A HEADS UP TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
PRESENTING BILLS AND JUDICIARY
HERE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT MONTH OR NEXT HEARING DATE
IS APRIL THE SIX WILL HAVE FOR
HEARINGS IN APRIL WE HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED BILLS TO HERE. IN
APRIL AND SO- I'VE CREATED A
FALSE EXPECTATION HERE IN THE
LAST TWO HEARINGS IS TO HOW
SHORT THE HEARINGS MAY BE- BUT
JUST A HEADS UP TO EVERYONE
THESE HEARINGS COULD GO VERY
VERY LATE- WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON. ON A- BEING CONCISE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE POINTS
THAT WE MAKE. ARE ONES THAT%
NEED TO BE MADE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT- MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL IF WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
STORY WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HERTZBERG.
FORGET HERTZBERG AYE BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE BUT TO
CONSENT ITEMS FROM THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND
WASHINGTON SHOULD TAKE SOME
LESSONS FROM THAT AS WE WORK
TOGETHER HERTZBERG AYE. BURKE I
HATE JONES HI JONES I LAYERED.
LAYERED I STERN. STERN AYE
STERN AYE. THE CEILING. WITH A
LAVENDER ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT NEXT. THE NEXT BILL IS S.
B. FOR SIXTY ONE. BARGES NOT
VOTING EARLIER- HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG I'D JONES NO. JONES
NO STERN STARTLING STERN I WANT.
TO YOU HAVE NINETY ONE BILLS
OUT. NEXTEL SB. TWO NINETY
SEVEN. AND TWO COUNTS OF
CULTURAL HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG I'D JONES HI JONES I
STERN. STERN AYE STERN AYE
THAT'S ELEVEN TO ZERO THANK YOU
BILLS OUT A FEW TO OPEN THE
ROLE IN NEXTEL NEXTEL IS SB.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR. HERTZBERG
AYE HERTZBERG AYE JONES FIVE
JONES I STERN. STERN AYE STERN
AYE THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO.
BILL IS OUT FELLAS OUT- IS
EVERYTHING ALRIGHT THANK YOU-
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED TILL APRIL SIX THANK
YOU.